jak se jmenuješ alice co chceš
říct
aspoň mě potrápit
obyvatelé Mariupolu
tak jsem na to
[hudba]
srdce nevinných začalo
Heslo
Zde jsme se vzdali, ale bylo to proto, abychom se postarali
v tu chvíli má koleno samé potíže
oskolki
ostřelování a náš trh už byl nepříjemný
za stejný klub
zkoušíme jako
nejsou nervózní a když střílejí
konstrukce praská
[hudba]
tak tohle je moje
situace je tam složitá a může být
tragický
ale
ona jsem jen já, vlastně jsem tu dnes
mluvil s prezidentským bardem
řekl dělníkům, co tam jdou
boj není boj
nedokončený
[hudba]
navrhovaný útok
průmyslová zóna
nepraktický
Nařizuji vám, abyste toto blokování zrušili
průmyslová oblast tak, že mouch
nepřítel
[hudba]
musíme se odtud evakuovat, jsme mírumilovní
obyvatelé to je to, co se stalo již lžíce
odpočíval za hospodou velmi blízko a nové
nádech
[hudba]
Jsem velitel pluku Azov podplukovník
dennis prokopenko se skrývá před o
světelné a jízdné přímo pro továrnu na čas
azovstal přicházejí ve stovkách civilistů
romadin od příbuzných je bohatý na děti a znovu
vika štěně sprue lidé něco rodin
obránci poblíž Mariupolu tyto uvay a mysl
Ruský svět v suterénu je bomba
zelenina chlap v ukrajinské visco vás
umýt pokračovat planety místa on
nepřiměřeně skryté, můžete tam skočit
Ruský obyvatel je v hale laboratorních asistentů
dnr s vědomím, že čistič zde civilista není s
když jsem letectví nevadí bunkr ne
bomby vystřelí rakety, to je pro každého
zjevné, nebo jsou v tom stvoření bombardováni
včetně brzy sfouknutého dramatického doupěte
likérové ​​školní lahve nejsou holčičí
zahradník byl vyléčen a vy jste tím, čím jsme my
o puna im bespeco pak můžete celý
evakuaci nikdo určitě předvést tomoya
za klikání na politiky všech civilizovaných
družina organizuje a zelený koridor je nezbytný
to zaručuje vedení školení bespeco
evakuaci civilních zraněných a těl
zabíjel válečníky a bázlivce, ale já ne
s vyznamenáním
[hudba]